[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا مشاهدينا الكرام تابعنا معكم مباشره
دخول العام الجديد 2023 في دبي مباشره مع
هذه الاحتفالات الضخمه من برج خليفه اطول
برج في العالم هي احتفالات اذن بدخول
العام الجديد في هذه السنه برج خليفه يعني
يحتفل بدخول العام الجديد برقم القياسي
جديد في احتفالات هذا العام بعرض ان
تستخدم فيها اشعه الليزر لتقطع اطول مسافه
مسجله
على الاطلاق اا اذا كما نتابع معكم اذا
دخول العام الميلاديه الجديد 2023 وتوديع
2022 كل عام وانتم بالف خير
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا مشاهدينا كل عام وانتم بالف خير مره
اخرى يعني تجاوزنا منتصف الليل ودخلنا
العام 2023 في دوله الامارات العربيه
المتحده على جنب الشاشه انه تابع جانبا من
الاحتفالات في محيط البرج خليفه في دبي
وكذلك الالعاب الناريه في اماره راس
الخيمه